would you rather see
to kill a mockingbird or just part two
of harry potter and i'm like for [ __ ]
sake dude i'd rather see harry potter
but not the second part
so i guess we're gonna have to see to
kill a mockingbird and i'm gonna have to
put on my game face i pretend like i
like plays
[ __ ] it maybe it'll be better than i
thought i went in with you know what i
went in with
an open mind
so i remember when i said you know i
tried to read the book when i was a kid
in high school and it was just you know
that's just like why are you trying to
make high schoolers read that [ __ ]
book and then we tried to watch a movie
and i'm like it's in black and white
and i'm like i'm not it's just not for
me i've seen the rock right
so
sit down and the theater's beautiful i
mean it's really small and intimate and
nice and we got great seats she got
great seats so she canceled the harry
potter seats and we got great teats of
this to kill a mockingbird play
i'm like all right you know what
they're impressing me with the [ __ ]
niceness of the theater and the theater
was probably built in the year four
so
and it's still up kept right like
there's so much gold and it's got a big
wooden set in the front like right in
the front there's like this big wooden
wall
and kristen's like is that there usually
or do you think and i'm like it's not
there usually
it's [ __ ] the set it's gonna rise
ah all right and then we're going to see
the other the more set that they have
and then to play did the thing that this
is the most like
[ __ ] pretentious [ __ ] that a play
does is
right away
right this is so this is how you know
you're in for a [ __ ]
banger of a play that no bones about it
just pretend city play when a guy walks
out before the wall rises and and and
like grabs a guitar and like starts
playing and i'm like oh just start
when's it start when the guy walks out
or or after the guy is this part of it
or what
start it when it starts
right is this gonna be one of those
plays where guys in the audience come
from the back with lanterns and they're
like we're looking for him
and you're like he's over there be
beyond us
why are you with us did you pay
a hundred and fifty dollars for a
goddamn ticket
go up there dude that's where you
rehearse
go near the guy with the [ __ ] guitar
that just literally sits there
for
five hours
and plays the guitar sometimes for
background music i'm like talk about it
[ __ ] where'd you get paid 40 pounds
and so
the place starts
and
i find myself
judging you know i'm in the biz right
okay cool
i get it i'm gonna i'll go acting in my
corner you know i mean right but i'm
judging but i don't want to judge i
catch myself judging right away
and i'm like all right you know what
dude stop just relax you're in a [ __ ]
building that was built in the year 11.
right
just chill
this is beautiful it's ornate as [ __ ]
these actors this is their job they've
rehearsed for this [ __ ] and it's written
by aaron sorkin so i'm like all right we
know his [ __ ] he did like the morning
show or newsroom or whatever the [ __ ]
and i'm like all right i'll sit down and
i'll watch this [ __ ] and i just i i
remember i walked in with an open mind
so i had to catch myself okay open
minded up let's keep your mind open as
[ __ ]
so i'm watching the thing
and it's about this dude atticus finch
that like is a lawyer and he wants to
like help this
you know the whole thing's about race i
don't know how much you know about to
kill a mockingbird but i guess you
should or whatever people consider it
you're cultured if you know what to kill
a mockingbird is
and uh it's about a black dude that gets
on trial for raping this nine this 19
year old
uh woman in in in in this play and
um
the uh
dad did it the the
ins it's incest the
dad did it
of the woman and he's trying to blame
this black dude for it
and it took takes place in like 19
whatever it is
50
40s
20.
i have no [ __ ] idea but the clothes
looked 40-ish 1940-ish 50ish 1950-ish i
don't know
uh or whatever it was after the slaves
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know i don't
know history dude and um don't come here
for history you come here for the
hard-hitting facts of today and so
i'm like
sitting watching this thing and it's all
about race and the racial tension in the
thing and i'm like
okay i
i get why they rewrote this for
i get it i get why david not david mamet
uh aaron sorkin wanted
i get you know and i catch myself
thinking oh i
yeah okay uh
it's it is yes i i know what you're
doing you're hitting me over the head
with it but okay
i acquiesce yes
it is also
still relevant today this okay you got
me dude you got me right i started
judging but now with an open mind i'm
sitting here
okay
i've got great seats i'm enveloped all
right i succumb hey guys i give up
yes
it's unfortunate
but it's still relevant today
okay
you win
now that's
35
or 45 or
seven hours i have no idea about time
in this play
i succumb to it all right
and
atticus just wants to do good right
he wants to respect people above all he
wants to respect people no matter what
their race he even wants to respect the
dad who did this [ __ ] because he doesn't
want to judge anyone
because he can't what he says crawl
around inside of their skin
now we've all been guilty of that
judging people and it's what i was doing
when i sat down in this theater that was
built
in the year
14.
and
his kids are mad at him atticus's kids
scout and finch are mad at him because
he's not
fighting he's not
physically fighting he's not yelling
why respect these [ __ ] if
they're racist why respect these people
if they want us dead
and
we do the intermission now there are
parts of the play where i'm getting
emotional but i'm keeping it as at bay
right the intermission happens
of course kristen has to go to the
bathroom because she's a woman and their
bladders are the size of a dime
and she comes back with ice cream some
[ __ ] how they weren't even serving it
and
it starts again the second half of the
play
and i'm watching the play
and this play is now in the trial of it
right in the thick of it the second act
and the whole play a lot of it takes
place in the courtroom right
and the jury
is in the back of the room like the back
like the furthest point from us we're
watching and i'm as somebody who's done
plays ntv and as acting in his corner
right
i'm wondering why the director decided
to put the jury in the back furthest
part
of the room because that means that the
lawyers will be talking to the jury and
we will be looking at their backs
most of the time when they're talking to
the jury and i found that i thought
interesting and i thought
i judged it wrong
i thought that's wrong why would they do
that why wouldn't they make us a part of
the jury
we would seem like we should be more
involved in this scene and all these
scenes and in this play i think it would
be better
that's me
judging
and there's a part where atticus finch
needs to give his closing arguments and
he was up all night writing his closing
arguments
and
in the
beginning of the play there's a scene
where
atticus says to his client
what
they're going to ask you why
you went in to help
this
19 year old white girl with her chores
what are you going to say
and the
accused
says well i went in because i felt sorry
for her and atticus finch says never say
that
that is the worst thing you could
possibly say say she looked like she
needed a hand
so later on in the courtroom scene
and one of them when the prosecutor is
grilling this man the accused and he
says why would you go in
and have and help a 19 year old white
girl with her chores when she has seven
brothers and sisters and he says i
wanted to help her uh i wanted to give
her she looked like she needed a hand
just what atticus said and he says oh
come on why would you do this and he
keeps grilling him he says i wanted to
give her a hand she looked like she
needed a hand and he keeps asking and
atticus fitch is like objection he's
asked five times now and then the
prosecutor says why would you do this
and then the accused says because i felt
sorry for her and boom just like that as
an audience we know they lost the case
right
we know oh [ __ ]
why is that bad we may or may not know
but we know that he was instructed not
to do it and he did it and now it looked
like they were winning the case but all
bets are off so atticus finch before his
closing arguments decide
to rewrite his closing arguments he was
up all night you know scout finch's
daughter tells us there's the audience
you know hey he was up all night and he
couldn't figure it out and right before
he gives his closing arguments he's
looking at his paper and he [ __ ] rips
it up
so now
i'm like
sup
right but in a different way
not in the same way as i saw the green
knight
and i was like this trite hollywood
piece of [ __ ] sucks so sup what you do
in hollywood i'm like in britain
watching this play
and i came in with kind of an open mind
that started closing again and then
checked myself and opened it a little
bit more
and now i'm like oh he ripped up the
paper that he rewrote all night last
night because he wants to
get this accused
not guilty
because that's truly
the truth
and so now i'm like
well
sup and i'm involved
and so he rips up the paper and he talks
to the jury
and he's talking to the jury and his
whole thing is he's saying like
you know what
yadda yadda you know about uh i was
gonna say this
and i was gonna say that
and the truth is
times are changing and this
we can start to change if you make him
not guilty because we know he didn't do
this and we know who did
and
he starts going on about how
the
world needs to change okay and he's
yelling at this jury
and this is like the first time atticus
finch you really see him kind of like
yelling
because he's a calm person the character
and he's yelling at the or at the uh
jury
and his back is to us and i'm still
thinking what the [ __ ]
and he starts talking about
how the world is this certain way
and he starts walking around
and
now he walks all the way around to the
front of the stage and he's still
looking at the jury so he's very close
to us
and he turns around to
us
as he's talking
and he says
now i'm already the emotions are right
behind the face right and he says
to as he turns around the first thing he
says is
we can't keep living like this
if we keep living like this and tearing
each other apart we won't be able to
survive
and i'm like
this is i i literally sink in my seat
because i think oh [ __ ]
i'm not just gonna let tears out
i'm actually going to
[Music]
whimper because i'm like
he's talking to us
but also
he's talking to me
and i'm like is this even the actor
or is this the character or is this the
act is this just the guy
this could be me saying this
dude and when i tell you i whimpered
because i had to keep i go
[Laughter]
like i'm not [ __ ] with you i go
like
like the biggest [ __ ] in london
just
and he starts saying when the mob comes
after you and you're and and it's unjust
and and i'm
[Music]
i'm a squeaky door in london dude
and then he turns back around and starts
talking
and i'm like oh thank god
thank god dude
i was going to cry so uh i was going to
have to grab onto the stranger next to
me and just be like is it okay
and he starts talking to the jury and
now he's at the jury and he turns back
to us from the back
and he's saying to us
you know i told him not to say
he felt sorry for her i told him to say
he wanted to help her because
uh she looked like she could use the
help
and in that moment you talk about
breaking and the prosecutor was trying
to break him and trying to make him
forget who he was he says that's what i
thought that he was going to forget who
he was but he didn't forget who he was
he remember
and i was like
oh
word and the tears just went [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh he didn't forget he did the exact
opposite
he
remembered are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
walls down
[Applause]
there
dude
i
am affected
i walked out of that play and when i
tell you i waited at the side door
for the actors to come out to tell them
thank you
i don't mean i waited for a few minutes
i mean i waited till they all came out
did
dude i
stayed crying the night dude oh i walked
out of that theater and i walked in
in a judgmental place and left
and actually thought you know what
if we all just tried a little harder
maybe we can change the world that's
what i actually thought
like a [ __ ]
i mean dude if i was i
bro i'm a play guy
i saw that [ __ ] and that [ __ ] really
affected me
i mean dude i get it if i was a dictator
in a country and that play came out and
i was trying to control the citizens oh
dude
that would get banned immediately
i would take one look at that play and
we had when he said
he didn't forget who he was
he remembered i would stand up and i
would say execute some all
there would be no more art
i'm different now
i'm going to more plays dude
i mean
i actually couldn't [ __ ] believe how
good that play was
and
it was the highlight of the trip dude
i whimpered tears came out like a
[ __ ] japanimation cartoon
i mean dude i cried like lucy and snoopy
you know
mouth all open tears [ __ ] shooting
out
and uh
it gave me like this new outlook on
life i don't know if it's even for a
little bit or what but like dude it made
me think like [ __ ] man
we should all be a little bit more like
atticus finch
and then afterwards kristen was like
we should if when we have another baby
we should name the middle name should be
atticus and this was an intermission i'm
like let's see how the rest of the play
goes you know and then at the end dude
with tears in my face i was just like
atticus it is
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]